i think what we're seeing is our values
were exploited
sowing division and this this western
imperialism of sorts whatever you want
to call it
where we have like the international
monetary fund where we have the un and
nato
the united states and their military
bases everywhere it's it's falling apart
like you're mentioning was it was the
the belt and belt and road initiative
yeah so china is
essentially giving loans building up
infrastructure in these countries
to then have massive debt that will give
them economic control
that's what the the western powers used
to do yeah or
still probably do well that's what
that's what colonialism was based on
it was it may not have been as say
concrete as what the belt and road
initiative is but it was basically
controlling territories to gain access
to the resources
in exchange for say example like french
colonialism
french colonialism was basically uh
we're going to exchange
whatever you got and we're going to give
you french culture because that's like
you know that's we're superior to your
inferiority
what we are seeing is china engaging in
neo-colonialism
it's effectively just colonialism but
you know it's in you know
from history till now they're starting
up a new process transactional
well but it's not just that it's chinese
immigrants
so china's a crowded nation they're
seeing a lot of you know the creation of
a lot of wealth as they expand
they then naturally want to move to
other countries to find opportunity
and to find more space i actually uh
interestingly enough about the belt and
road initiative is that they don't even
hire locally
they bring in their own workers from
china to exactly
these you know whatever level of
infrastructure roads bridges
buildings you name it tunnels it's all
that that doesn't stimulate the local
economy
all it does is just uh put these
countries into debt
and that's right make them beholden to
the chinese communist parties
isn't that what the imf would do
basically yeah so
so listen china is absolutely displacing
the western
strategies and and foreign policy and
they're sending in chinese workers a lot
of countries
many people who are just regular old
citizens citizens of china are naturally
just
immigrating other countries there's no
plan there they're just doing it because
they want to move they want to find a
place then you end up with lots of
chinese immigrants and other countries
setting up their own little communities
in chinatowns and things like that
then you get the belt and road
initiative which creates the economic
power structure
eventually you're gonna have many
countries which are just going to be
like second world satellites of china if
not they already are
and the us people don't seem to realize
this we you know we we we talked about
this i think earlier in the week that
manufacturing in the in the u.s
actually is up a little bit like one
point something percent
year over year but we don't produce all
that much relative to many other
countries our principal export is
the us dollar for for buying oil so we
prop up the petrol dollar
with the threat of war to anybody who
dares drop that dollar
the us is in is in a crumble is in a
very difficult
position it's you know we've got joe
biden who apparently is struggling to
walk up these stairs the wind blew him
over i kid you not they said the wind
blew them over i mean
that was not a good excuse they could've
said he tripped and that we could have
moved on
but joe biden falls of the wind blew him
over wow you've got hyper polarization
you've got a 50 50 split basically in
our government senate is 50 50
and then the house is like 219 to 211 or
whatever like
just as narrow as it can get they're
trying to remove some dem
uh uh they're trying to remove a
republican who was duly elected and
certified to
it's just it's falling apart our
international systems are failing
the international wars have failed our
our way of controlling other countries
is falling apart and china is assuming
all of
it and i have to wonder how many special
interests
millionaires billionaires and
corporations in the us have already seen
that happening
and are moving their businesses over
that's back to their best exactly that's
been right
nba for instance yeah no it's been
happening for a while disney
um apple yeah i mean manufacturing and i
mean
manufacturing in china is really cheap
especially when they use weaker slave
labor
right right so uh well but thinking
about it this way
if the us dollar does crumble bitcoins
at 58
700 or whatever yeah these companies
have already moved
to china and they're already like you
got mark cuban defending china
what what is what does he see that is he
is he hedging his basically saying he
thinks china's gonna win this one
china's already won that's actually what
i wanted to say is that bill maher
uh interestingly enough and i agree with
him on a lot of points even if he
even if he didn't get everything right
in his his little monologue from from
last week
he pointed out how china already won
yeah they're not they're not winning
they already won because
the fact that we're still bickering over
things like the culture war
cancel culture you name it you know
these are things that are
so they're distractions to the bigger
picture
and in terms of global influence you
know the united states
are you know we you know that i saw a
t-shirt once that said word number one
but there was no apostrophe in it
[Laughter]
word number one yeah
and so like you know while the united
states economy still is number one in
the world as as i said we're still
we're number one baby i mean that is
that's those days we're number one it's
like the patriots dynasty ending
i never really got into the whole like
we're the best thing because like when
you're at the top you're just a target
people want to rip
you down we should be part of an
integral group of allies that are
working we were though yeah we really
should like russia and
britain and england well not russia but
we
we did have western trade alliances nato
the u.n
yeah and that power structure is failing
i mean look the coalition that went into
libya was it like france
you know the u.s a couple other
countries i guess look at the coalition
of the willing or whatever going to iraq
it wasn't just the u.s it was a bunch of
different countries
expressing this you know control i mean
we they they
well after 9 11 there was uh they
invoked article 5 of
of nato getting uh us to the point where
we had every nato nation as well as we
got uh
australia and new zealand uh involved in
and uh in a basically the invasion of
afghanistan which then turned into the
invasion of iraq
i mean it just it for some reason
uh the united states loves war we're
never going to get out of it and
that has depleted our economy
tremendously
and if you ever want to talk about how
climate change impacts it
you know it doesn't help it
you guys ever hear the non-aligned
movement no it's basically the united
nate the other united nations on earth
there's the united nations that we know
of and then all the countries that
aren't involved with it are in this
united group of nations called the
non-aligned movement who's not who's not
who's in it
iran is that that is where they're
headquartered was in iran for a while
um uh was like the chairman of it
um yeah thank you for pronouncing that
properly
there's like 92 countries or something
some insane number and don't quote me on
that number but
it's it's all these countries that the
united states is basically doesn't want
to have diplomatic ties with these are
the people we need to be allied with
yeah well there's also bricks the bricks
nations i mean
[Music]
that's the thing is like so
iran and the united states are
their interests are diametric
diametrically opposed you know iran
wants basically hegemony over the region
the united states
uh i mean the iranian regime
has been on the path of tariff for quite
some time funneling
money to hamas hezbollah
you name it they've been killing our
guys and our men and women overseas
um i don't imagine that's gonna happen
anytime soon unless of course
president biden tries to get the iran
nuclear deal going on again
uh god help us if that happens but um
look i am i am fine with like making
friends with other countries
so long as it doesn't isn't to our
detriment we're not being taken
advantage of and i
don't think that the iranian regime is
would be acting in good faith
i'm looking at like china like the nazi
party and if we had allied with russia
before the nazis invaded poland we could
have possibly prevented it
what do you mean well because we weren't
really on good terms with russia before
the war
russia wouldn't come to france's aid
about world war ii yeah okay and so this
is like a modern day like we're on the
cusp of another world war with another
you know racist ethno state right and
unless we ally
now with russia and india and iran and
all of these
countries around china if they're going
to do some crazy well the thing is like
china and iran are basically in bed with
each other
because um i mean when iran doesn't have
you know any of its allies to go to if
it doesn't have the united states to go
to
say funnel them cash they'll go to
russia and they'll go to china
because china definitely wants to have
them on their side yeah
anyone who's an enemy of the united
states is their friend
so and like we're talking about it's
it's
china doing everything their power to
expand their influence to that to anyone
who's willing to listen
and i think that i wonder if there's
elements of the us
that are worried about war so they're
already essentially resigning
to the fact that we will lose i think it
was uh uh we were talking with kurt he
said there's war games
with that the us has done with china and
all these war games we just lose lose
lose
i i can only imagine there's a lot of
really rich people who are probably like
all right well if that's inevitable
i'm gonna move my money over i'm going
to move my money to china and focus on
that business
and then in 50 years when this whole
system in the west falls apart
china will be the dominant superpower
and you will have a
an authoritarian ethno state exerting
their cultural influence over all the
other countries
on the planet i would argue obviously
and i don't know if i said this before
but i i'll
if it sounds like i'm repeating myself
then i apologize but i think
uh richard nixon's greatest mistake was
not anything to do with watergate it
actually had to do with opening or
opening the united states to china
because we for some reason
i don't know what miscalculation took
place but it was a miscalculation
and i was assuming that the chinese
communist party which at that time had
only existed for about
about 20 21 years after the the chinese
civil war
after world war ii that
by introducing capitalism to them they
would somehow modernize
and what they did is they basically
adapted they kept their system in place
and they basically turned their society
into
a pseudo capitalist one that encouraged
commerce
and encouraged other other you know
corporations from other countries namely
from the united states to come to them
you know get cheap manufacturing build
their their
products and then ship it across the
globe and
they did it by consolidating as much
power as they needed to
and by they i mean the chinese communist
party and
we're basically at a loss we
underestimated china
100 percent we we thought money and
greed would win out and we
underestimated
the resolve and the ideology and the
power of the chinese communist party
so we were hoping that our money was
going to go in
and that essentially greed not
necessarily greed but like commerce
and a better life would open up the eyes
of these people and they would say oh
we should we should do that because
it'll make us money and then eventually
that would weaken the the power
structure in the communist party they
didn't realize how hardened it was
so what ended up happening was the
communist party exploited all those
systems around it to become even more
powerful
yeah and it we just fed the beast we
also underscore
and probably we we discount the
confucius institutes here in the united
states yeah
that's a very it's it is a very real
problem but not one that's discussed
very often
and that is how a number of different
universities in the united states
have these institutes called confucius
institutes and
what they do is that they basically
it's like exporting the ideas of the
chinese communist party to
you know you know malleable minds in the
united states
um but also you know you can look at the
chinese exchange students who come to
the united states
and i'm not saying that them coming here
is bad but what
ends up happening is they start to adapt
or they start to adopt some you know
values that we here in america embrace
they start to get you know maybe think
that like american values are actually
much better than chinese values
and they correct that issue right away
that they have like sort of a
self-policing system
and so if any if any exchange student
gets out of line
you know they're gone yeah
i think man it's like we're on that
we're on the we're on the back end of
that bell curve it's the golden age is
is is over for us it's been we've been
interested for real guys
yeah it's been fun by bitcoin uh no no
no no financial advice
i'm buying bitcoin buy gamestop
i actually don't buy games no china
bought a bunch of bitcoin a lot of
bitcoin oh yeah
so thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have
full bonus episodes thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time
you